et pour en parler avec nous sur ce
plateau morad el hattab auteur du livre
saif el islam kadhafi un rêve d'avenir
pour la nuit aux éditions eric bonnier
morad el hattab vous êtes également
écrivain donc je ne le dira mais
philosophe aussi et vous êtes lauréats
d'ailleurs du prix littéraire pour la
paix et la tolérance merci d'être avec
nous c'est moi qui vous remercie
alors première question est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de cette réunion selon
vous permettent elles d'entrevoir au
moins un espoir en tout cas d'apaisement
pour la libye nullement
et c'est encore une fois on accouche
d'une souris
parce que la seule véritable question
qui n'est pas posée c'est on part tous
de tissus démocratique mais on propose
pas une élection en libye c'est quand
même assez surprenant
pourquoi aucun moment on dit que on va
permettre l'avènement d' élections afin
que le peuple libyen qui n'est pas
présent est pas entendue dans cette
réunion puisse s'exprimer librement
alors les dirigeants des principaux pays
concernés par ce confiant tout cas les
pays qui étaient représentés lors de
cette réunion hier à berlin s'engage en
tout cas à arrêter leurs interférences
donc ça veut dire qu'ils admettent ces
interférences
quelles sont elles et à quel point elles
ont freiné la sortie de crise en libye
bah de l'interférence et l'adieu depuis
le départ dès 2011
la france a mis en place les intégristes
au pouvoir par le biais de monsieur
bellaciao ces combattants d'al qaïda
puis gouverneur de tripoli se disant
combattants de la liberté
et depuis nous avons deux gouvernements
à tripoli monsieur sa rage qui se
déclarent une liste du gouvernement
libyen alors qu'il n'a même pas été
reconnus par la chambre des
représentants libyenne n'est par le
conseil général libyen mais selon les
accords de red hat supervisés par l'onu
et puis haftar qui s'autoproclament
maréchal et qui effectivement avait fait
des élections à tobrouk
donc on a comme ça une partition du pays
et où étrangement des pays autres essais
chacun de tirer la couverture à soi
par rapport à des intérêts purement
liées aux matières premières
alors vous en avez parlé un de cette
intervention militaire de 2011 on se
souvient des dégâts actuellement on
essaye en tout cas les pays et
institutions s'attelle pour trouver une
issue diplomatique à ce conflit libyen
meskine ici diplomatique elle est encore
possible en libye à l'heure actuelle non
pour une raison très simple c'est que je
vous le dis le marché la star ne signera
jamais ces accords jamais pour une
raison aussi très simple c'est que
récemment le
mais c'est sa rage a signé avec la
turquie des accords d'exploitation de la
zone souveraine libyenne méditerranéenne
pour l'exploitation de pétrole et de gaz
c'est une saisine souveraine des biens
libyens par tard ne signera jamais tant
que les turcs sont présents avatar ne
signera pas aussi simple que ça et par
ailleurs je tiens à rappeler comme le
rappelait très justement le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe
l'intervention libyenne fut une aventure
illégal et criminel donc laventure n'est
pas prêt de se terminer
sauf si éventuellement on force à des
élections puisque haftar de toute façon
ne signera rien il n'a même pas intérêt
à signer puisque il veut expulser
de fait toute présence intégristes dans
le prochain gouvernement
et il est appuyé pour se faire par les
émirats arabes unis l'egypte et l'arabie
saoudite et en sous main la france donc
de toute façon ils ne m'aiment pas
intérêt à signer quoi que ce soit
d'autant plus que l'offensive militaire
aujourd'hui lui est favorable
alors pourquoi on en parle encore d'une
issue diplomatique alors vous venez de
le rappeler on sait très bien que très
récemment la turquie a envoyé ses
troupes en cdi ont des seins des plans
militaires pour soutenir justement fire
elle s'arrache d'un côté on nous parle
18 diplomatique et de l'autre on sait
que ni terme et se prépare à faire
confronter votre question est d'autant
plus pertinente pourquoi parce que
jusqu'à maintenant la série payer des
mercenaires
majoritairement syrien avant ça il dit
des irakiens et des afghans
aujourd'hui on voit très bien que la
tuque essaient de rentrer dans le jeu
diplomatique
malgré tout et mais moi je vous dis
clairement ce qui tient la main de la
résolution du conflit sont les états
unis dont parle pas les russes et
éventuellement les turcs et c'est
pourquoi
je n'en suis pas intimement convaincu sa
rage ne restera pas puisque de toute
façon il est de plus en plus illégitime
c'est pas impossible que lecture que
c'est de trouver une issue favorable
un néant une poche annoncera tard
puisque majoritairement les libyens qui
sont présents sont d'origine turque et
ottomane
afta éventuellement prendra le pouvoir
haftar éventuellement sera obligé de
fête d'enclencher les élections
présidentielles et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on verra apparaître la figure du fils
prodige le seul reconnu aujourd'hui par
le conseil des tribus libyennes saif
el-islam kadhafi
merci beaucoup mourad et la table pour
savoir si vous êtes écrivain et
philosophe et titulaire du lauréat du
prix littéraire pour la paix et la
tolérance
merci